ground around the Empire State Building
appears to be sinking
this Historic Landmark is about to get
lost in a giant pit and you will be
coming down with it
if a sinkhole swallowed the Empire State
Building would you be safer at the top
or the bottom
what would the warning signs be
and could anything increase your chances
of survival
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the Empire State Building was
swallowed by a sinkhole
okay sinkholes don't open up all that
often but sometimes Earth's subsurface
Rock dissolves creating underground
spaces and caverns
slowly but surely the hole continues to
grow in size
if these Caverns get big enough the
ground gives way sinking everything that
was on it
these trap doors of nature exist all
over the globe and they can be as
shallow as 0.3 of a meter or as deep as
30 meters
it would take an enormous sinkhole to
swallow the Empire State Building and
our planet has just the right spot for
the task
so how big would an abyss need to be to
consume this iconic building
the Empire State Building measures
381 meters it'll take you almost 2 000
steps to climb it the building runs from
33rd to 34th Street beside Fifth Avenue
and holds a Workforce of about 15
000 people
add to that it's many visitors on
average approximately 11 000 go through
its doors each day
so only an extraordinarily massive pit
would be able to consume all of this
skyscraper it would be the sinkhole to
end all sinkholes
so meet the Heavenly pit
located in China it's the world's
deepest sinkhole at 537 meters wide and
around 650 meters deep
it's so huge that if we built the Empire
State Building inside the pit there
would still be about 270 meters from the
top of the building to the edge of the
sinkhole
so let's say a sinkhole just like it
formed in Manhattan
and since all great things should have
great names let's name this one the
infernal pit
now before the devastating collapse New
Yorkers would notice strange things
happening around the Empire State
Building
doors would start jamming outside the
trees would tilt toward the ground
fresh cracks would spread on the
building's base and the area around it
if you were enjoying the view from the
observation deck on the 102nd floor
you'd be at the wrong place at the wrong
time
down on the street people would hear a
muffled explosion followed by violent
snapping and cracking noises they'd try
to run away but it would be too late
in an instant the ground would fall into
a colossal void the Empire State
Building would plummet right into the
sinkhole taking you and about 16
000 others with it
now with luck the building could
withstand the fall without crumbling
thanks to the sturdy Central core and
supportive bracing on the other hand
most of its 6 500 Windows would be
demolished as much as you'd want to see
what was happening you'd better stay
away from the windows unless you want to
get slashed and bleed out
but those flying shards of glass would
be the least of your troubles people at
the bottom of the Empire State Building
would free fall for a staggering 650
meters the entire depth of the sinkhole
in contrast you and others at the very
top would drop about 270 meters
that's a big difference but sadly the
odds of surviving would still be against
you
you know just falling from three meters
could fracture your spine and ninety
percent of people who fall for seven
stories die if you fell from the 102nd
floor well as a famous man once said
it's not the fall that kills you it's
the sudden stop at the end
[Music]
could attempt to soften your Landing by
jumping up as the building falls
unfortunately though this would only
slow you down by five kilometers per
hour at most
you could also lie flat on your back
which would spread the force of impact
across your body
the downside is that your soft tissues
would absorb the full impact
that includes your brain and try living
without it
now if by some statistical Miracle you
made it through the fall
you and any survivors could try climbing
out through the smashed windows
meanwhile people in the lower levels
would be buried under Rubble and you'd
have a long wait before Rescuers arrived
first city Engineers would check dangers
from the gas lines water mains and
unstable foundations
firefighters would repel down the
sinkhole making rescues slow painstaking
and Incredibly risky
now thankfully it's nearly impossible
that this New York City Landmark would
face such a calamity
maybe it's destruction wouldn't come
from below but from above in the form of
a mega tsunami
but that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]